alain houpert radiologues et sénateurs a
l'air de côte d'or estime lui que la
gestion du collier 19 a été calamiteuse
en france on l'écouté mais les études
sont les études 12 journées de cette
gestion du coc vide où il ya eu une
étude calamiteuse du land 7 qui voulait
absolument dénigrer un traitement pas
cher le reste l'hydro xi chloroquine ce
titre max on était dans le la phrase de
molière cacher ce traitement efficace
que je ne saurais voir
on a eu une gestion calamiteuse du coc
vite 19 qui a mené à confinement qui
était une réaction de panique par
rapport à la pandiani et par rapport à
l'attitude de la france où la france a
été quand même le seul pays qui
n'avaient pas de masque
il est important de garder ses distances
1 garder ses distances sociales physique
ne pas être en contact avec des gens qui
vont aussi garder ses distances du
rapport à une désinformation
parce qu'on parle beaucoup de
actuellement on parle de contamination
il est évident qu'on traite tout le
monde donc on proue des cas